[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP JAN DEPAUW:
Lighting is something
which is pretty static.
You think about it when
it doesn't work anymore.
The change with LED
is that it not only
became greener and
more sustainable,
but it became intelligent.
GEORGE YIANNI: Philips Hue is
an internet-connected lighting
solution.
FILIP JAN DEPAUW: You can steer
your lighting with your voice,
have the lights
change with music
when you have a party, as
well as an element of comfort
and security in it.
GEORGE YIANNI: When we
launched Philips Hue,
we didn't know whether
we needed infrastructure
for 1,000 people or
a million people.
We wanted it just
to scale and work.
FILIP JAN DEPAUW: So our choice
of partners was fundamental.
We needed that scalability,
that back end, that robustness,
that maturity.
That's why we selected Google.
GEORGE YIANNI: We've worked
with the Google Cloud team
since the very beginning.
At the moment, we're running
on the Google Container Engine.
This is working
fantastically for us.
By breaking our application
down into containers,
we have all these small parts
that we can deploy, release,
test independently, and
that's allowed us to move
to much faster release cycles.
We were able to spend less time
tinkering with infrastructure
and more time focusing on the
applications and the use cases
for consumer.
We are really getting
close to the cutting
edge of what's there.
FILIP JAN DEPAUW: We're
growing tremendously,
and we want to make
sure that we can
deliver the lighting experience
we want in every single home.
[MUSIC PLAYING]